get ready for Congress to give enough
standing ovations to get in a year's
worth of squat workouts
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is coming back to Washington
this time to warn Congress about the
Iran Threat well who have a lot to share
here are five things you won't be saying
that you should know
so Netanyahu's got a bit of a track
record of overhyping threats remember
his famous remarks at the UN when he
said that Iran was less than a year away
from building a bomb well recent
intelligence cables leaked to Al
Jazeera's investigative unit show that
Netanyahu's own spy agency the Mossad
contradicted that expert analysis just a
month later according to the Mossad
cable Iran was not performing the
activity necessary to produce weapons
but maybe bee bees just keeping up with
his own tradition more than a decade
earlier he went before Congress to make
a case to go to war in Iraq and today
the United States must destroy the same
regime because a nuclear-armed Saddam
will place the security of our entire
world at risks and we all know how that
turned out
well then Yahoo is making a fuss about
Iran he's conveniently omitting who
actually does have nuclear weapons
Israel the country's estimated to have
80 warheads and on top of that it has
not signed the nuclear non-proliferation
treaty a global ban on new countries
developing nuclear weapons but guess who
has signed the NPT Iran not only does
Iran go through the most rigorous
nuclear weapons inspections in the world
it'll be subject to even more intense
ones if a u.s. Iran deal goes through
the deal that the Obama administration
is negotiating actually it's going to
close off every possible pathway for the
Iranians to build a bomb
the IAEA will have cameras at all of
Iran's facilities it would have the
ability to make spot checks and also to
make inspections that undeclared site
Bibi wants you to think that Americans
are so happy to see him but he's
actually causing a firestorm in
Washington and hurting his country's
relationship with its biggest ally
Republican House Speaker John Boehner
invited him to speak to Congress without
consulting the White House or the State
Department which is a breach of protocol
Obama won't be meeting with Netanyahu
during his visit and Vice President
Biden who's also the president of the
Senate will ditch his speech as will
several other members of Congress on top
of these snubs the White House
spokesperson has even called out Bibi
for running his mouth we see that there
is a continued practice of charity
repacking specific pieces of information
and using them out of context to distort
the negotiating position in the United
States so then why is bebe so dead set
on coming to the hill and derail in u.s.
Iran talks as treati Parsi told me
Netanyahu doesn't want the balance of
power in the Middle East to change
Israel fears that a deal with strength
in Iran's regional influence the nuclear
issue never really was the primary
concern of the Israelis because the
nuclear issue is actually getting
resolved what was the issue then is it
the big issue
she's the geopolitical balance of power
in the region the fear that the United
States striking a deal with Iran will
legitimize Iran as a regional player and
that it will reduce the United States
commitment to the security of Israel to
the security of Saudi Arabia Egypt and
other states that have been traditional
American allies in the region hmm what
else is Bibi not telling you well his
speech to Congress might just score him
votes back home in Israel's upcoming
elections but given all the drama he's
bringing and the things he won't be
saying is Netanyahu making the wisest
move
hundreds of top-secret documents